عادل فكرك فيه اطباق طائره
باق طائره انا مش اطباق اكل يعني
فضائيه طائره انا هذا يعني مش مهم اصلا
بالنسبه لعادل للاطباق الطعام هي طائره
دائما على كل حال مشاهدينا هناك اطباق
طائره فعلا لا يعرف مصدرها تحلق فوق سماء
كوكبنا سؤال قديم جدا ما زال يطرح يوميا
لكن لاول مره في خضم الجدل حول القضيه
وكاله ناسا تشارك بالموضوع ليصبح جدلا
طابع علميه الوكاله الامريكيه شكلت لجنه
وبحثت في 800 حادثه
لتعقد مؤخرا اول اجتماع على نيه مع
الجمهور لمناقشه النتائج والمعطيات
الحاليه رئيس اللجنه
قال ان البيانات الحاليه وافادات شهود
العيان لوحدها ليست كافيه للتوصل الى دليل
استنتاج حول طبيعه وا كل حاله فعل كما انه
عمليه جمع البيانات لم تكن دقيقه لانها
افتقرت لمقاييس السيطره النوعيه ومعالجه
البيانات فيجب ان تكون هناك مقاربه تحرص
على تطبيق معايير دقيقه في جمعها المزيد
حول تاريخ تطور فكره الاطباق الطائره
ومخلوقاتها الفضائيه مع
لميس ابراهيم لميس
لطالما ارتبطت القاعده العسكريه المن
عزه للعباده مشاهدات الكائنات الفضائيه
والاجسام الطائره يمنع التصوير او حتى
الاقتراب منذ عام 1955 ظلت المنطقه لغزا
لملايين الامريكيين فقد كانت قاعده سريه
لتطوير طائرات استطلاع تجسس خلال الحرب
البارده ولكن ما اسهم اكثر في ترسيخ
علاقتها بالكائنات الفضائيه ما اعلنه شخص
يدعى روبرت ليزر عام
1989 وذلك في مقابله مع محطه اخباريه في
لاس فيغاس حيث ادعى انه عمل في المنطقه 51
وقال انها تضم مركبات فضائيه وان وظيفته
كانت اعاده انشاء التكنولوجيا الخاصه بها
بهدف الاستخدام العسكري ليتضح بعدها انه
لم يزر المنطقه اصلا اقرت الحكومه رسميا
بوجود منطقه 51 لاول مره في عام 2013 لكن
لا تزال قاعده ناشطه والغرض الذي خدمته
منذ السبعينات هو لغز غامض للغايه سوف تمر
بضعه عقود اخرى على الاقل حتى يتم رفع
السريه على العمل الحالي
طيب من الكويت سلامتك من الكويت ينضم
الينا استاذ مساعد بكليه الدراسات
التكنولوجيه سابقا الدكتور محمد قاسم
دكتور صبحك الله بالخير اهلا وسهلا
نورتنا متى تنزل من المركبه الفضائيه اللي
انت فيها
لا تقولون حق احد خلوها انا خايف من
الفقره الماضيه الشتيمه هذي تاثر علينا لا
لا
طيب يعني جريندايزر يمكن طلع صحيح اللي
احنا تربينا عليه وبالتالي
اطباق طائره
ما يصدق العقل هل ناسب دخلت الى هذا
الصراع ولا انسحبت ولا فهمت خطا ولا شنو
حاليا يعني مسوين لجنه علشان يتاكدون من
هذا الموضوع يشوفون اذا كان فعلا هناك
اطباق طائره ولا لا كل هذه الصور اللي
اعطوهم اياها والفيديوهات من تقريبا 800
فيديو 600 منهم كان قديم 200 منهم كان
جديد
فكل يعني غالبيه الفيديوهات
95% منها العلماء كشفوا انها ليست الا
فيديوهات عاديه يعني مثلا مثلا
ليست مفبركه قد تكون فعلا موجوده لكن فهمت
خطا مثلا هناك 5000 طائره عفوا 5000 يطير
1500 الطائره تطير في الاجواء حاليا وفي
كل وقت هناك ملايين الدرونات موجوده في
الهواء فلما الناس تصوروا ما تعرف شنو هذه
الاشياء ناس تدخلت بموضوع وكانت تاخذ بعض
الفيديوهات مع توقيتها مع المعلومات اللي
موجوده فيها فكانت تبحث هل كانت هناك
الطائره في الاجواء في هذه اللحظه ففعلا
يتضح ان هناك اشياء مثل هذه يعني المساله
بسيطه كشفت عن كثير من الاشياء وبقت اثنين
الى خمسه بالمئه يعني للحين مو كاشفينة
الدكتور ليش تاخرت ناسا لغايه الان لحتى
تعمل هذه اللجنه او الاجتماع
للتحقق من هذه الفيديوهات رغم انها
فيديوهات موجوده منذ سنوات ان ما كانش منذ
عقود وفي يعني مجموعه كبيره من الناس
خصوصا في الولايات المتحده تؤمن فيها
والموضوع كبير ليس بالموضوع الصغير يعني
لماذا كل هذا التاخير لحسم الجدل لديها
ادلتها يعني طبعا كلام سليم جدا جدا وفعلا
ولكن لا ننسى ليست الجهه الوحيده اللي
عملت على هذا الموضوع يعني مؤخرا لكن هناك
جهات اخرى عملت عليها مع الحكومه
الامريكيه من فتره طويله وتكلموا عنها
وقالوا ايضا انه ليست هناك ادله على وجود
فض ائيين زاروا الارض لكن ناسا اليوم
تشارك في هذا الموضوع بتوصياته لها عاده
التوصيات بالحكومه يلا تدخلي في الموضوع
وايضا هناك نقطه مهمه جدا وهي تريد ان
تخفف الوصم على هذا الموضوع يعني في ناس
تخاف ان تقدم فيديو وفي ادله معينه على
وجود فضائيين او شيء اخر لكن ليش يفتحون
هذا المجال الان لان الحكومه الامريكيه
تريد اي واحد يصور مثلا
شيء غريب ان تقدم لهم حتى يكشفوا ما اذا
كان هناك سلاح معين لدوله معينه تستخدمه
فاذا هناك لهذا حتى تستفيد امنيا طيب هذا
من ناحيه من ناحيه العسكريه او
استخباراتيه لكن اليوم في ناس ايضا يطرحون
هذه المواضيع باعتبار انه والله لا هذا
امر واقع اليوم العالم كله يفكر الى
الهجره الى القمر الى المريخ الى الى
كواكب اخرى ثانيه اذا هناك عوالم اخرى
ثانيه هي ايضا تاتي الى الارض فبالتالي
لماذا نطلق العنان او ناخذ بحكم انه لا
وجود للاطباق
لا عفوا العلماء وايضا هذا السؤال جدا
ممتاز العلماء لا يقولون لا وجود للاطفال
هم يقولون كل الادله التي قدمت الى الان
لا تدل على ذلك فيما عدا جزء بسيط يحاولون
يكشفون عنه فعاده يبحثون فيما هو موجود
على الارض وبعد ذلك ينطلق العنان لما هو
في السماء فهم لا
يقولوا اشياء ممكن تاتي من السماء لكن الى
الان ما في دليل على ذلك شكرا جزيلا موجود
حقيقيه وطائره وفعلا جزيلا لك دكتور محمد
قاسم استاذ مساعد بكليه الدراسات
التكنولوجيه شكرا لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات